hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to bad dream Cyclops I
imagine this one will have a lot to do
with poking people's eyes out because
that seems to be a theme in this type of
game
but either way turn down your lights to
not be a volume put on headphones and
get ready to enjoy this Cyclops not like
that that sounds weird okay so this is
oddly Pleasant I imagine that I'm in
some camp with some woods and some Jason
type Cyclops is gonna come out and
everyone that's good - Cyclops stomping
through the monster I'm so I'm not the
cycle is less that's a mirror is that a
mirror probably not okay
I say oh alright did you bite off a
finger please tell me that's a finger
and not something else oh you're such a
good Poochie what would you do good blue
G oh let me pet that eyeball of yours
okay hey leggy lady man person okay so I
probably shouldn't mess with you with
the skull and crossbones and all that
old unused weaponry okay
this village is already kind of weird
tooth fairy looks like a mosquito with a
trumpet for a horn
okay so tooth prop puff Blair equals one
penny rate
I saw a Blair oh boy you wanna fight me
for that finger there you wanna mess
with me puppy fine oh it's a mommer's
why did I do that
oh just callin bones this one has a lot
more intricate detail to it
which is good I guess why is this a
thing
hi oh it's Jason Oh Jason
okay this is bizarre there's a lot more
environment here okay so there's a lot
[Music]
good I can get an op for one penny I
just I can barely see that through my
what I I am the Cyclops okay so good I
guess
okay so man there's a lot of map to this
game say that oh my eye has turned into
a bloody socket so I can't even see
things correctly good I've lost all my
depth perception okay so I got a hammer
and I got pliers no markiplier jokes
please I've heard of all I've heard them
all there is no need for markiplier
jokes next thing I know when I read this
all comments just markiplier jokes okay
so I get a hammer and some pliers and an
unused eyeball you want to go with me
bruh oh I get okay okay
okay you want an eyeball you want a
hammer to the face I got a bone he's
gonna be happy about that and I bet oh I
got a tooth okay so I just need to take
this tooth I need to use it with the
finger good to go right
Oh muffin things oh my god ear that's
not what I wanted that's not what I
thought it was at all I thought it was a
finger oh it's a pillow oh okay I slowly
put the tooth in his face why am I so
stupid of course I put it under his
pillow it's the freaking tooth fairy
I didn't know Barry was gonna come check
that place okay so now that I get that I
know that an OP is one penny and when I
have that OP I'm gonna be able to do
whatever I want
what that is I do not know you want a
penny you want trained an OP for a penny
you know a penny up I got another one
okay cool I needed what needed one go
ask why buck to me penny wishing well
[Music]
you're at a hairy body oh good what did
they do to me
I got a mask great okay you want a mask
you want an ear what do you want oh what
the hell happened here why is he gone
why is it why
oh it's still locked though oh okay
oh don't think I did that oh no my
Penny's gone
oh good thing I got another tooth though
okay where's my money
give me my money thank you I need to go
get my money in the thing so I can do
the thing ear for ear fairy oh I know
where the all that is okay oh okay I see
I see how this works I see what a dick
you are I see the [ __ ] that's
happening in front of my I know exactly
what you're doing is that the
illustrious call of the ear fairy
fluttering his or her way into my heart
give me mine whatever oh it's an earring
oh okay I put that in there I fairy oh I
wonder oh I wonder so hard I'm wondering
so wondrously know exactly
oh god my alarm went off whoops oh I
guess it's 6:00 am good for me
so I need to find a pot well any that's
what I need to do right now I need to
find a pot so when I get the pot I can
put something in for the offeri cuz that
what we all oh good I found a pot I got
a half coin was my eye now worth a half
going huh
something tells me I did I did bad is
that the thunderous steps of the Cyclops
oh that is oh that very much is oh I'm
so happy I did this oh wait oh he's very
upset
oh he's very upset oh good oh good
hey doggie are you doing what you don't
want me going in there what are you just
so vicious you don't notice the giant
Cyclops stop it around I got a key damn
it I got a damn key you need to find
like another bone or something ponies oh
oh these guys are bloody Oh
oh ho oh ho okay so there's got to be a
bone okay yes of course I'll just steal
from the dead like I always do have a
bone me I'll go in here I'll take
whatever the hell this is crowbar good I
like
what does that thing also sorry for
blasting everybody's eared oh this is
drawing from this hospital oh good
we're both Cyclops brothers oh that's
the end okay hard panic inducing heart
inducing oh it's cool it was so cool
like each one of these it's the same
theme but it takes a little bit
different Avenue and I love it I love
these games these games are so good it's
so good it's hard to even explain like
why it's good it's it's such a simple
little bite-sized piece of fun and like
just just horror if ik enough but it's
drawn in such a simplistic way that it's
not like totally understandably gruesome
but it gives the idea that it's gruesome
and at the same time it has a story that
makes you want to perceive like there's
something more to it but at the same
time you kind of notice there's a bad
dream it's all weird and wonky
let's go cool I love these games so much
I'm gonna keep playing I'm gonna keep
playing these games are fun so thank you
everybody so much for watching check out
the other games in this series if you
have not already they are awesome and I
can't wait to play the last two so I
don't know if the developers made any
more after these games but hey kudos to
the developer check out the page of
where I got these games on gamejolt they
are awesome games thank you everybody so
much for watching thank you very much
and as always I will see you
[Music]